I mean for those of you I haven't met
yet I hope to meet you today sometime
welcome welcome to the University church
this is a very strange and special
places you've already figured out
probably at home they didn't have you
singing in Hindi or doing all these
things we are deliberately global Church
and so as you represent the globe here
at Yale so we try to represent the
global Christian community in our songs
and our prayers so if you have songs or
prayers from home you'd like us to sing
or include we'd be happy to do that but
we want to represent all the places and
traditions you come from so let us know
this church not the building but the
church itself is one of the successors
of the original Yale church which was
founded by and for Yale students in 1757
purportedly because the preaching of the
pastor at center church was not strong
enough for the spirited young men of
Yale in fact Thomas clap the president
right up here in the window said he
described the preaching as thin gruel I
hope to do better welcome to this Chapel
building battelle which has also been a
place of Solace and inspiration to
generations of Yale students since 1767
it is a strange building it is a bread
box built into a quadrangle with all
this wild decoration not a
congregational church at all but here we
are this was what they decided in 1867
and we love it it has become home to
many of us as quirky as it is and it is
a beautiful place in the midst of an
urban campus you are welcome here
anytime anyplace Candis and I are happy
to meet you for coffee to talk to get to
know you we would love to this
awe-inspiring building and hot building
there was no AC in 1867 may feel a
little intimidating to you but in coming
here you enter a long line of Yale
students whose faith has been supported
and challenged and grown through their
years in this very building it may feel
very different from your home church but
we hope that in a few weeks it will
become home
for you but I've been thinking about
those young white men who were sitting
here back in 1867 for daily prayers and
I realized there is one difference
between them and you many differences
but the one I was thinking of is that
they were required to be here and often
grumbled about that requirement if you
read the histories so we are grateful
that you're here without coercion people
come to church on their first Sunday of
college for many different reasons
because mom and dad told you to perhaps
because in some cases mom and dad
actually got you up this morning and
brought you here because you live in
farnham and the organ practice woke you
up so you decided to come to church
because you've gone to church every
Sunday of your life because you've never
been to church and you wanted to see
what it was about perhaps for many of
you it's simply because it was in the
opening day's schedule and you've done
every event listed in the opening day
schedule including the Portuguese
placement exam and tryouts for the
Quidditch team perhaps you're here
because you loved your home church or
youth group and our sequin to recreate
that experience here but I want to
suggest another reason that you're here
today that you might not have considered
that God brought you here it may sound
like a quaint notion that there is a
supernatural force capable of sustaining
the universe that could at the same time
be concerned about what you one Yale
freshman is doing on sunday morning
August twenty six twenty twelve scholars
may scoff at the possibility as they
scoff at the idea of free will itself
they would say you didn't choose to come
here and God didn't bring you either
your being here is merely the result of
accident genetics history and
evolutionary impulse somehow an
uncountable number of mostly random
events convinced your genes that there
was a reproductive advantage to your
me to church this morning who knew I
wonder what Timothy Dwight or Jonathan
Edwards would say about that but I want
to suggest that God brought you here not
because I'm the kind of person who
believes that if I find a quarter on the
sidewalk that God put it specifically
there for me I want to suggest the gut
brought you here because God cares about
your decisions and not only that God is
actually part of those decisions you may
feel like you're here on your own you
may feel like whether you're religious
or not is entirely your decision but I
want to suggest that God is intimately
involved in your life and you in God's
it's actually a rather daunting
possibility because it implies that you
are here at Yale not merely because you
are incredibly intelligent talented
motivated hard-working though I know you
are if God cares then it is possible
that you are here because a force
greater than your own accomplishments
wanted you to be here could anything be
bigger than my own accomplishments oh my
gosh Ian you are breaking up Yale what
is the undergraduate admissions office
going to say that's why yes all about
it's all about my accomplishments and
more accomplishments 10 times more a
hundred times more sign me up for every
day this idea that God cares is daunting
because it might imply that you are here
not entirely because of your plans even
and Yale people are planned phul people
but because your plans aligned with a
much greater plan and even more daunting
that if your personal plan might diverge
from that greater plan at some point the
greater plan might prevail oh dear I
know you've been on a path since you
were in second grade you've been on the
treadmill one more step one more
addition to the resume
I'm gonna get their hard work hard work
all the way what if God gets in the way
would you be bad what if God said
suddenly I want you to step off the
treadmill for a moment and explore life
with me no wouldn't happen in our gospel
passage today the fifth and final
passage from the sixth chapter of John
that we've been reading over the last
five sundays we've had plenty of John 6
Jesus summarizes a meditation in which
he describes himself as the bread of
heaven sent from God to feed the
spiritually hungry and to satisfy that
hunger eternally Jesus as bread choosing
language that was almost certainly
intended to offend his own Jewish here's
Jesus says those who eat my flesh and
drink my blood abide in me eat my flesh
and drink my blood Jesus was not
advising cannibalism don't worry
probably wasn't talking directly about
the Eucharist either he was saying that
simply believing is not enough those who
want to follow him and through him be
reconciled to God need to get close
intimately humanly fleshly close you
need to be able to smell God and these
words did offend his file his own
followers say this teaching is too
difficult who can accept it this was not
the god they thought they knew their God
was unknowable holy up in heaven mighty
and just transcending all the world in
all flesh and humanity was way down here
utterly finite passing and sinful and
the two could never meet God could never
be bound up in human flesh the very idea
that God could come down from heaven was
offensive and blasphemous father John
Shea one of my favorite spiritual writer
says the way we ordinary religious
people think is such that we believe
that God is completely other and people
are completely earthbound
people are from Earth and have glimmers
occasionally of a higher world but they
never belong to it people are physical
beings with spiritual intuitions but can
never be spiritual being seeking ever
greater incarnations Jesus reverses the
direction of religion it is not we who
through our decisions decide what we
will believe and then aspire to God
rather it is God who in Jesus reaches
into the world and brings divinity to
fleshly human life and people can by
taking Jesus in by discovering his
consciousness become not just animal
seeking the sky but children of God
incarnated and fleshed in the mess of
this world it is too much for many of
Jesus's disciples to hear they pack up
their bags and they leave I think this
is good evidence for the historicity of
Christian what other scripture would
include the fact that most the people
got up and left in the middle of the
story they don't want to believe that
God could get involved in human life in
such a messy real intimate way God's
over here in God's box and all the rest
of life is over here Jesus seems to want
to say just the opposite we are a little
box and God and divinity is surrounding
us if only will open up Jesus asked the
few who will remain is this teaching too
hard for you to do you want to go and
Peter responds where else can we go you
have the words of eternal life we all
imagine I'm sure that if we were there
we would be among the faithful few like
Peter and not the disgusted majority
after all you're here on Sunday morning
and your suitemates are sleeping you're
on the good side but are we really ready
to hear Jesus is difficult teaching are
we really ready to eat his flesh and
drink his blood to make him part of us
not at communion which were many of us
is so easily done but in our daily lives
are we ready to admit that we are not
entirely in charge of our lives in our
future but that we participate in God so
literally that
directed not by our talents and our
desires and our plans but by a deeper
purpose a more complex meaning a fuller
justice and holiness than we can
manufacture ourselves there is something
good there is something bigger than me
father Shea again talks about teaching a
class of the seminary where he teaches
in which he requires his students to
read a really advanced spiritual texts
and they struggle and they complain and
they find it confusing and even
offensive but over time they keep added
paragraph by paragraph until spiritual
insights they'd never imagined come
through he says he tells them I think
this is the one message I want you to
take away today never waste your time
reading a book you could have written in
our walk with Christ too often we
presume that because we were raised in
the church or had a conversion or read
through the Bible from Genesis to
Revelation that we know Christianity
pretty well and we could write the book
ourselves but even for me and people in
this church who are much wiser and more
spiritual than me there is still so much
to explore and understand we're not done
the temptation are in our religious
culture is to say that if it's difficult
to skip it it's not worth it the Trinity
too hard morality justice evil too hard
Christianity should be easy it should be
comforting and generically good and
moral and positive imagine what would
happen if you had this attitude about
organic chemistry it's Jesus worth as
much effort basically today for many
Christianity is a nice hobby but the
Jesus who speaks through John's gospel
today will not be happy being a
lifestyle or a style a subculture or a
club the Jesus who speaks in john wants
to get into our lives and mess with them
and we have to be ready for that the
Jesus who speaks in John challenges us
to trust him and now
to listen to these hard teachings until
we can struggle our way to understanding
we do not choose this Jesus this Jesus
chooses us often those who do not yet
believe presume that Christians are
people who one day in deep thought
decided to believe rightly or wrongly
but those of us inside the church know
that faith is really not an intellectual
or a lifestyle choice it is rather that
we like Saint Peter have to say where
else can we go you have the words of
eternal life christian faith is an
awkward compulsion fueled only by the
deep hunger we feel to be as close to
God as God's own flesh and blood we do
not choose it in all its messiness but
we do realize that no other path works
for us last spring Lauren Burk one of
our student deacons who graduated you
have a courageous sermon here that i
quoted many times she said that she
lived in fear through her yale
experience fear that every choice she
made a class a major and internship
might be the wrong one the one that took
her off the remarkable path of success
in her life away from the plan God had
for her she said that she finally
overcame this fear by developing a
deeper spiritual understanding that she
hadn't had before that God was not
pointing her down a single path that if
she strayed off that she would somehow
lose or lose God but she said she
realized that whatever choice he made
even no choice God would be there the
life of faith is not the treadmill of
success it is a halting journey more
like a crazy video game than the flight
of an arrow it promises new amazing
revelations at every turn it promises a
wisdom that overcomes the turbulence of
our feelings and our fears it promises
an intimacy with God that fills us and
embraces us it promises mistakes and
forgiveness resilience when we stumble
sustenance when we are hungry and
thirsty for a deeper purpose
than just our own plan this church I
have to tell you now is not perfect we
will make promises to you that we won't
always keep we will sometimes say one
thing and do something else we will
sometimes pretend to know this
especially applies to me when we don't
but we do promise to be with you every
step of the way we promise to tell you
the truth even if it hurts we promise
not to tell you the right answer before
you've had a chance to speak we promise
to listen to you and to love you we
promise to continually challenge you to
live out your faith by serving the
suffering around us in New Haven but
also a Yale we promise to do our best to
do a few simple things to love God to
love each other and to do something
about it we promise to look at you as an
individual with a story and a set of
dreams and unlimited possibilities and
we promise that though we may sometimes
falter to look at you and see the glory
of God amen